it's time to fight for titles the best
juniors girls and Senior chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri for the U.S junior
girls and Senior championship
beginning July 15th 30 players will
compete across three fields for over a
150 000 prize fund
this tournament features the top Junior
and senior chess players in the nation
including the young up-and-comer Karissa
yip
Young Junior Phenom ABI Manu Mishra and
returning senior Champion Alexander
shabalov
three titles are on the line and you
won't want to miss it catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch channels